last februari in March fashion designers
showed off their creations for
fall/winter 2016 at Fashion Week's in
New York London Milan and Paris with
hundreds of collections and thousands of
outfits on display there is lots for the
fashion conscious woman to choose from
fashion journalists like Isabelle Brown
pick out the hottest trends the young
German then writes about them for
publications like online fashion
magazine more derpy Lord which means
fashion pilot it fends dowon you're
fondling as friends last more than a
season but there tend to be more trend
pieces in winter simply because people
tend to wear more in winter and
something Guan bama an athenian had two
major trends from past seasons are still
hot this winter first GU tification the
wild patterns and retro styling favored
by the Italian fashion label continue to
excite fashionistas and secondly the
gender bender trend in which the
boundaries between men's and women's
fashions are increasingly blurred at
apropos a high fashion store in the
heart of Munich Isabelle Brown shows us
how these trends have continued to
develop
the dominance from gorgeous noguchi
continues to dominate many many brands
have adopted its style with a lot of
mixing of patterns it's a vibe you can
see that here for instance there's the
floral trend with lace and color
contrast yes this more is more
maximalism has produced a new femininity
or greater femininity I have too tight
again and in accordance with the gender
bender concept more pants and blazers
are offered in less feminine materials
then bye dad I'm more that's much
because you haven't traditionally male
materials are now appearing in women's
fashions you also see more feminine
elements in men's clothing like
decorations are patterns um echo hot
soon or da Mosta here desert-survival
this decorative stripe is really
feminine and would otherwise not be seen
in menswear do you think my social you
can also see it here with these patches
on the jeans I'm pretty sure most people
couldn't really say whether these pants
were made for women or men I never was a
foot there Vince jeans and a heaven
posle along with the major trends there
are some smaller ones to watch fashion
blogger Isabelle Brown points them out
at over Paulina an upscale department
store in Munich
we're in vintage photos based in the Sun
Velva is absolutely the trendy material
for winter 2016 no longer from PR just
for covering sofas it's now being
reinterpreted with casual cuts or in
sporty variants there's no getting away
from it this winter even Thomas 14 by
and just as hot what does Anna and death
harmful inventor and some red is one of
the colors of this winter a really nice
signal red not Gordo but pink is also
trendy even for men what's that I've got
four men up and with it mm-hmm final and
patent-leather are really important this
winter it girls like Alexa Chung wear it
all the time and important designers
like louis vuitton show did you talk
what's old is new again he's eat man no
I can see you can clearly see the return
at femininity we have very girly things
with transparent materials ruffles and
frills this trend extends to virtually
all areas and I dentist Sean lehenga
that's a trend it's been a long time
coming but has now hit stores with a
bang is f leisure that means workout
we're integrated into everyday dress
classic ah here's a classic the hoodie
it label vatta mom has everyone fired up
again for the street where look there
remain that way for a while and then
there's the Renaissance of the down
jacket this winter staple is now called
a puffer jacket and it's the latest
thing
to the design arms in guns guns light
when many designers showed them in very
light and thin variations or they made
them really oversized as a statement
piece that's vicious tick and how I
styled is very important push down off
the shoulders and have to see how that
works in everyday life that's vandread
on a house in listen chilly winter
weather has yet to arrive in much of
Europe but these new fall winter
fashions will have many saying let it
snow let it snow let it snow